c'est mon préféré marie-claude monette
enseigne au collège citoyens à laval
elle magazine des costumes pour son
école mois puis mon collègue on a mis
une valise deux sacs à dos puis on a un
budget plus on dépense tout fait que
c'est vraiment la plus belle journée nos
élèves
ils vont pouvoir s'épanouir dans le
théâtre avait plein de beaux costumes
pour une première fois en 40 ans
d'histoire
l'opéra de montréal a mis en vente des
costumes pour faire de la place dans son
atelier des centaines de personnes y ont
participé
c'est l'opéra de montréal cyclonique sa
première fois puis tu un morceau de
l'histoire mais c'est super d'avoir
accès à cette qualité-là de costumes et
un petit peu d'histoire aussi de l'opéra
que je chéris beaucoup à mon kart
dès 5 heures du matin des curieux ont
fait la file pour trouver des pièces de
collection
les trois mille costumes disponibles ont
été vendus
c'est ce qu'on a fait un certain élagage
pour pouvoir donner accès aux jantes a
plutôt des morceaux peut-être qu'on ne
remettra pas sur scène parce qu'elles
sont moins au goût de jour -
techniquement utilisable mais sont
encore en très bonne état parfait pour
l'halloween
un carnaval et pourquoi pas la vie de
tous les jours chaque année je veux à
mentir à la nouvelle orléans donc ça
prend beaucoup de costumes donc c'est
une bonne occasion dans la mort plaide
chez shaw et pour moi qui voyage
beaucoup et c'est parfait pour la viande
mais seuls prix des morceaux 5050 150
dollars au maximum
avec cette activité l'opéra de montréal
veut démocratiser l'accès à la culture
c'est principalement pour rembourser
l'activité puis au prix où on vend les
costumes l'éducation là dedans qui ont
coûté entre cinq et dix mille dollars à
faire à l'époque
donc c'est vraiment
c'est pas une activité comme tel de
bénéfices mais l'opéra de montréal
espère bien attirer de nouveaux
spectateurs ici marié cousineau radio
canada montréal